When we last tossed you talked, you recommended clear digest when I read the recent blog about
H. Pylori. In it, you talk about testing with Apple cider vinegar. Okay, so let's do this.
Let's go to that blog and upload that up, the dookie. So the blog post is this one. All right,
so I'm going to try to change my share. Okay, so everybody can see this new share now. Okay, so here's
the article, the blog post. He looked back to Pylori, information and care. H. Pylori, most common
bacterial infection worldwide explains a little bit what H. Pylori does to our body. Kind of
important, H. Pylori suppresses the prinal cells. The prinal cells are the cells of the stomach
that are responsible for making HCl. HCl, and I think on this video down here, I didn't actually put
this video on there. There was a video I made about 10 years ago on how H. Pylori has made it,
and I didn't even listen to the video. But I think this is my video that explains that in the process
of making H. Pylori, when your body, when your prinal cells make H. Pylori, the byproduct is
is hydrogen is sodium bicarbonate, and sodium bicarbonate that acts as a buffer in the blood. And remember,
I said your blood is constantly buffered, and your body is constantly buffered. If your blood doesn't
need the sodium bicarbonate, it pushes it to the tissue. So actually making HCl can help
alkalize your tissue. And deficiency in HCl, a deficiency in your prinal cells ability to make HCl
is probably the number one health physiological malhealth in the planet period. And which can
explain one reason why we have more acidic tissue than we probably should. So HCl is super
important in our body. So added HCl to a meal is really important because that takes pressure off
the prinal cells and it allows them to start producing HCl again. So when you add HCl to a meal, it
doesn't have a negative feedback loop like adding a hormone to your body when shutting down the
gland that's making the hormone. It doesn't shut down the prinal cells of making HCl. It stimulates
them even more because it takes pressure off of them. So it allows them to recover so that they can
start making HCl. And by making HCl, it will also produce sodium bicarbonate for the tissues to help
alkalize you. It should make a video on that. So a decrease HCl causes iron issues so it can cause
anemia issues, can cause osteoporosis, can cause SIBO, which is small intestinal bacterial overgrowth,
decreases our microbiome diversity, which is a huge thing that leads to leaky gut issue. It causes
in systemically, it gets into the bloodstream and causes damaged vascular endothelial cells.
It damages the endothelial cells and the smooth muscle underneath the endothelial cells. It is one
of the top five reasons for cardiovascular disease worldwide. It is the number one cause of
stomach cancer worldwide. It's a molecular mimic to different antibodies in your body. Hpylora is,
it can cause an autoimmune attack on the prinal cells, the stomach cells. It can be the cause of type 1
diabetes. It can be, like I said, the cause of cardiovascular disease. I see the Hpylora be
caused major rashes in people's skin. The list goes on on what Hpylora can cause it. It's all because
of decrease HCl production. This is a loop here. So a decrease HCl sets up Hpylora. Hpylora increases
a loss of the HCl. So it's really important to be taking a digestive enzyme with HCl. That's why we
have a private label that clear digest because it has HCl and a good slew of digestive enzymes.
So you need digestive enzymes to help break down different things. Protein fats and amylase to
break down carbohydrates. And those are mainly made in your
pancreas, so you make some of the prinal cells or in the crotted gland as well. But mainly made in
the pancreas, it's created in the droid. The HCl is made by the prinal cells and the stomach
is created in the stomach and when you have a decrease HCl it is a major issue. So it's good
article to read. But sometimes people have such a decrease in HCl that when they take a clear digest
with HCl and it causes burning the stomach ache and it can't even take it. Well, then you know
that's first and as very similar HCl deficiency and they may have to start with this little protocol.
So this little protocol is take one to two tablespoons of apple cider vinegar with each meal.
If that causes burning too. So if HCl taking HCl with digestive enzymes causes burning,
okay, we've got major stomach issues, quite possibly a stomach ulcer. If taking two
tablespoons, one to two tablespoons of apple cider vinegar with each meal, oh my gosh, I can't
tolerate that either. My stomach is killing me. Typically this is a person that's taking a PPI
like PPI or something like that. We're trying to get them off of PPI. And if this is causing burning,
then we have to go and work on healing the gastric lighting, which is like using the
glycerized licorice and different stages that will help just heal the stomach lighting. We have to
do that for a couple of weeks to a month. But most of you, I haven't had anybody that's been this
bad for quite a while that couldn't even tolerate apple cider vinegar, but you could just follow
this chart. So if this is you, so the person who asked this question, let's go back to the question,
in you talk about testing with apple cider vinegar a few years ago, I was taking apple cider vinegar
and developed terrible-paid and murdered. I had to go on prilosec to get better. So a prilosec
will really decrease your symptoms, but that you do not want to go on prilosec,
less your life depended upon it. We got to heal up the stomach, using things like slippery
almond, there's different herbs and marshmallow and different things like that that will help heal
the stomach. So if you take HCl and you get murdered, if you take apple cider vinegar and you get
murdered, it's a sign that you have really damaged your coastal lighting of the stomach and possibly
the duodenum, possibly the lower part of the esophagus, and high possibility of an ulcer. So we have
to heal that first. And you might have to go on an antibiotic for a period of time to kill the
age pyloric, also to knock it down and then treat that. So I would start with the clear digested,
and most people can tolerate, so I wouldn't be afraid of taking HCl. It's going to do worst-case
scenario, it's caused burden for a little bit. You're only taking it with your meal and it's only
going to cause burden for a few minutes if it's the worst-case scenario, so.